ici à voisins le bretonneux pas de
plateau de télévision
la 30e édition du téléthon s'est
déroulée dans le gymnase des pyramides
l'endroit a été transformé pour
l'occasion achat de livres buvette
entraînement sportif et spectacles il y
avait mille façons de donner pour la
recherche de traitements contre les
maladies rares
quel que soit son âge sa taille sa
religion son truc on s'en fiche quoi
l'importance de penser aux enfants qui
sont malades aux familles qui bat qui se
prennent une gifle les élus de la
commune se sont eux aussi mis à
contribution leurs pédalage alimentait
une partie du gymnase en électricité
pour tous ces jeunes qui ne peuvent pas
avec leur handicap faire du sport et
bien nous on essaye de mettre justement
les muscles à l'honneur pour eux et
surtout pour que les gens fassent un don
donc on va pédaler jusqu'à 19h ce soir
on a commencé à 10 heures ce matin pour
participer aux activités sportives pas
de somme minimale chacun donnait ce
qu'ils voulaient un principe auquel a
adhéré jérôme et sa famille venue exprès
pour l'événement c'est un moment des dés
de convivialité et aussi de
sympathique et joyeux là c'est
aujourd'hui c'était du sport
tout le monde peut être touché par des
maladies neurodégénératives tout le
monde paye victime d'un grave accident
donc personne n'est à l'abri du besoin
d'une recherche médicale optimisée et le
fait d'associer là population à ces
grands projets de recherche
je crois que c'est un élément
fondamental à la fin du week-end ces
animations ont permis de collecter plus
de 7000 euros au plan national ce sont
80 millions trois cent mille euros de
promesses de dons qui ont été atteints